I'm on one of them sisters you don't hit
so you can't hit sisters period met me
in the old days and you could beat up a
woman remember that [ __ ] back in the 20s
guys and smack their wives in the movies
a dish let's go you can't do [ __ ] like
that no more women be taking aerobics
their [ __ ] you up
[Applause]
it's scary to man especially a black
woman a black woman she lose her mind
she seriously go crazier you can have a
real timid sister for a girl and smack a
be like I'm gonna kill you [ __ ]
your hand in my face
put him up
faded Lisa
ah stop baby hold up stop please please
calm down baby calm down
you don't hit me [ __ ] let's get
the [ __ ] out
so Yash your own house should be so sad
you get the [ __ ] out - awesome [ __ ] you
know you scared when the woman say get
the [ __ ] out your own house and you
leave I had a girlfriend once I smacked
I got all cool on and [ __ ] and then she
got cool - scared me more and should I
just left but that slap then got my show
I said I didn't wanna do that [ __ ] baby
but you bought that [ __ ] on yourself but
made me have to do it again I said no no
I did bring it on myself I did why don't
you just go to sleep and still to this
day women only earn 70 percent of what
men earn in the workplace and of course
that's disgusting
how dare women earn so much
a lot of things that I say tonight will
be jokes that I don't actually mean but
this is something I'm really passionate
about women do not deserve to earn as
much money as men in the workplace I'm
sorry I am NOT being a misogynistic
bastard right I'm not saying that women
don't work as hard I'm sure they do I'm
not saying they don't do as good a job
what I'm saying is they don't deserve to
earn as much money as men right men need
that extra 30% to buy meals and drinks
and Jim Jefferies tickets and all that
[ __ ]
I'm sure there's women in this room that
are saying I pay for my drinks I bought
my ticket and don't think we don't
appreciate the Uglies because we do I'll
tell you guys from from my pants
I'm telling you about things I went
through okay you don't want to do it
this is when I first find out my lady
was crazy we was on the highway and she
hit me first of all anybody that hits
you when you're on the expressway of any
kind don't care about their life let's
get that out okay we're on the highway
be coming from an event you know my kids
in the backseat and we arguing I mean
you know what your problem is you don't
respect me as a man
okay so you respect me as a man we're
gonna always have problems that's why I
fight so much how does he I'm thinking
about putting my hands on keep on and
I'm gonna show you what that feel like
cuz you stupid I've been so afraid for
my life dude I looked in the back my
daughter my baby against me and
everything you got a no got a know your
woman fellas don't be afraid to be a man
fellas I don't care what you gonna do
you relationship don't be afraid to be a
man stop being yes men no woman wants a
yes man don't think that's gonna make
you feel your relationship better
because you agree with your woman all
the time it's not gonna make your
relationship better it makes you look
stupid
you're just saying yes all the goddamn
time huh yeah yeah yeah yeah wait what
do you mean yeah I get it yeah yeah
yeah yeah we yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'll pick it up yeah what now just left
you ready to go back
yeah man [ __ ] foot gives a ball here man
argue that's what you in a relationship
for you in your relationship to argue as
we're men a tear for we argue even when
you wrong
argue I've been caught red-handed
several times argue you want know how
you win every single argument be laughs
so you got do when they can't hand to
that women can't handle when a man's
voice gets past a certain level they
break down they don't know what to do
I've been court just mean what you say
Matthew say it walk out you can't stick
around you gotta you gotta if you stick
around you give him a chance to come
back and confuse you say your point get
the [ __ ] out the room go Kevin
I saw you I saw you Kevin I saw the
[ __ ] in your car you come in and see
you shut up shut the [ __ ] up man every
time I come in the house you have to
microwave all ha [ __ ] you
[Music]
you can get it
[Applause]
she'll be staying in like wait I thought
I thought he liked it when I use the
microwave I don't I don't know I don't
understand him or what he wants from me
anymore I don't understand me and my
lady boy I don't mind women leaving me
no see but they tell you why yeah [ __ ]
that just leave like cuz ain't [ __ ] you
can say when they talking to you right
you know it's true all you can do is
stand and look silly right and [ __ ] gets
too thick right [ __ ] got a great
answer we'll [ __ ] it then
take your [ __ ] and get out
yeah [ __ ] pack this [ __ ] you
packing [ __ ] pack this [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] with me Batman how do you
[ __ ] him to put it under your drawers I
don't give a [ __ ] with the kids
[ __ ] I'm gonna find me some new [ __ ]
women come back at your ass all right
yeah - more than just a dick you find
some new puzzle
[Applause]
No are you just trying to [ __ ] with me
see no you don't want me jump on you
answer you have something to say when
you leave I ain't going [ __ ] [ __ ] I know
the dick was good to you every wasn't
good why was you hollering I was harder
to keep from laughing in your face
not all the time you have to regroup on
a woman jack you know now stay out think
I asked but we out reason in
[ __ ] see if we get two minutes
and all we gotta do is get two minutes
but it's hard to break down
[ __ ] up when they get a roll
going they leave you in the middle of
four babbling baby you have to go to
your psychology bag on there hey wait
[ __ ] on this organ you know me that's
this sir be cool all right
just take your time and pack your [ __ ]
all right take your time pack your [ __ ]
put your [ __ ] in the bag is that bad
gonna be big enough cuz if not you can
use one of mine right you cool you got
money and everything goes I guess you
don't need no Matt you COO what do you
mean I just wanted to be right [ __ ] I
can't make you stay if you want to leave
you just go ahead and pakis you
understand we started off as human
beings I wanted to in that way you do
all you have to do is find another way
out of here open that door but you try
to leave me [ __ ] I'm okay all right
I'll put the [ __ ] bag
what the goddamn back
[Applause]
like there is no reason to hit a woman
there is no reason to hit a woman and I
was just like really I could give you
like 17 right at the top of my head you
can wake me from a drunken stupor I
could still give you like 9 do there's
plenty of reasons to hit a woman you
just don't do it
but the sit there and suggests that
there's no reason through the level of
ego behind that statement
what are you levitating above the rest
of us you're never annoying women how
many times have you thought about
slapping your your [ __ ] guy in the
head this week there you go every day
you didn't do it right I'll do drives me
nuts there's no reason there's no reason
really no reason how about this you
marry a girl you fall in love you buy
her house you go to work every day
paying off the house you come home one
day she's banging the next-door
neighbour hand you divorce papers you
got to move out sleep on a futon and
still pay for that house that she's
gonna stay in no reason I'm not saying
he should do it but there's plenty of
[ __ ] reasons in that arc of a story
really assess a thing I hate that saying
there's no reason obviously I'm not
saying they hit a woman you know but
saying there's no reason I think that's
crazy
when you say there's no reason that
kills any sort of examination as to how
two people ended up at that bet that
place you say there's no reason you cut
out the build-up you just left with the
act how are you gonna solve it if you
don't figure it out
look how awkward it is in here right now
I said you shouldn't hit a woman I'm
just saying how come you can't ask
questions you can only ask questions
about what the guy did you can never ask
about the woman why is that why is that
what is that what is what is answer them
right me what does that mean
are you the idiot who got up halfway
through the special during the bit and
you're like walking around like on that
[ __ ] taping a special here what's
wrong with you what's wrong with [ __ ]
had to ignore all of that and now you're
gonna like yell out and not only that
yells something that makes no [ __ ]
sense whatsoever answer him
answer him every [ __ ] special like
though there's always one oh it's right
down the [ __ ] middle talking about
hitting women sweethearts and I think
you just added another reason
these is [ __ ] christ I love this I'm
not even in a relationship with her and
she's [ __ ] nagging me
[ __ ] some believe ladies let's
discuss it Luke let's discuss harassment
for a second
what why can't I harass you
sometimes sometimes
[Applause]
I can never harass you ever and I'm not
talking about like I'm talking just
[Applause]
at the job it's unfair that I can't
harass you at the workplace like
you're looking how you looking and I
can't just a little something that has
to do but you gotta be careful just to
say hey you look beautiful today
that's how messed up the game is I think
you should be able to comment on any
part of the body that you see if you I'm
saying what's your name what's your name
Jeanne now Jeanne no disrespect but if I
work with you
I swear to walk in and go oh Genie
beautiful titty meet you have that
[Applause]
because I see that but whatever the
scientific term is look at that list of
a 4.9 grade point average Worcester
what's the science term for tip the
titty meat what's the actual and it's
not the cleavage I mean the cleavage is
the space in the middle I'm talking
about the meat that the meat the titty
and I'm not being foul just now you know
you don't say just so I can go through
the rest of the day without pretending
then I don't see much we eat you
understand let me let's work out a deal
don't get me fired
having women work with men right is like
having a grizzly bear work with salmon
dipping honey like so
now you dip the salmon in the honey
right grizzly bears and the salmon get
to walk through comfortable with honey
and fish and good morning grizzly bears
and the grizzy fans design Brown what's
our fish oh my god Human Resources the
grizzly bears is the president so
like I can't even go hey good morning
good morning fish good morning oh I
can't touch like y'all look at that let
me just get a little bit of that fish
look good look at that honey
Oh
[Applause]
Bishan money and that's my favorite
usually I kill fish and eating them stop
but I just wanted to just rub that rub a
little bit
damn partner weeks ago I failed to
perform sexually I'm not gonna go into
details suffice it to say I arrived
early girlfriend said don't worry that
happens to a lot of guys said right I'll
stop you there couple of things firstly
who are these a lot of guys and secondly
if it's happening to more than one of us
don't you think it could be your fault
see relationships are hard
but for order for any relationship to
work both people have to be on the same
page
both people have to have the same focus
just right and we all know what that
page is we all know us that focuses in
order for the relationship to work both
people that I have the same focus and
what's that focus the focus is all about
her it's all about her she's already
there fellas she white and feudin come
on fellas when you wake up in the
morning you should look yourself in the
mirror and say [ __ ] you
[ __ ] your homes [ __ ] your fridge [ __ ]
your plants but everything you thought
this life was gonna bring you now let's
go out there and try to make this [ __ ]
happy
yes it's all about heart fellas say yes
to everything everything everything you
could afford say yes to just say yes
before she even gets it out of her
[ __ ] mouth honey can guess honey I
wanna guess how do you have I guess it's
gonna stand yes yes yes yes
another thing fellows don't argue you
cannot win you cannot beat a woman and
an argument it's impossible you will not
win cuz men we are handicapped when it
comes to arguing cuz we have a need to
make sense
[Applause]
women ain't gonna let a little thing
like sense [ __ ] up a argument cuz she
nodded at the sin she said it but
distance and irritation how long could I
talk before this [ __ ] steps
they want you to shake the [ __ ] out of
them do you hear the cops come
that's right like I said try your best
to make her happy
try that but here's one thing nobody
tells you you can't make a woman happen
it's impossible I've never met a happy
woman in my life what it always
complaining about something she women
like two can play women save up shipping
complaining about oh he don't even know
I know but I'm gonna get his ass on that
[ __ ] next one
they like [ __ ] complaining they love
it
no matter what you do she'll be mad Yuma
[ __ ] a woman with a diamond dick and
make a [ __ ] pimp I just still could play
why you made me [ __ ] so hard this diamond
dick is clouding why don't you go to
Tiffany's you're so [ __ ] cheap no
matter what you do yo woman is mad at
you if you work all the time let your
girl
you ain't never hope you always leaving
me I hate this [ __ ]
if you home all the time why are you all
up under me let me get some [ __ ] room
to breathe damn stop sweating me I hate
this [ __ ] if you make more money [ __ ]
you
I want to make decisions too you ain't
my [ __ ] daddy I'll need you to take
care of me I hate this [ __ ] if she makes
more money than you
you broke my love bugger you never have
no [ __ ] money [ __ ] - I don't want to
make all these decisions I need to be
taken care of I hate this [ __ ] I can't
take it
and the number-one reason yo woman's
always mad fellas there's nothing one
reason yo woman is pissed the [ __ ] off
cuz you ain't her first choice
darlin you ever catch your woman just
looking at you but not saying nothing
and her mind she's thinking how did I
end up with this ugly [ __ ] Oh
Lord this [ __ ] ugly and stupid
I had a good man and I blue damn Lord
killed my man gentle please kill him
while I still look good enough to get
something new please kill this
[ __ ] now strike strike please
note that the percentage of these pie
graphs do not add up to 100% because the
math was done by a woman
those are you hissing at that jerk it
should be a notice that that joke was
written by a woman so now you don't know
what the hell to do no I'm just kidding
we don't hire women